three days ago as you may have seen my
focus
was on the immediate past on the
importance of leading with truth and
integrity
on the difficult times our country faced
in lockdown
and on the fact that those who make the
rules
shouldn't break the rules
now i set out my position on that
question
and the difference between me and the
conservative party now desperately
trying to launder its integrity
eve even as it stood
by an unfit prime minister
to the bitter end
today i want to put my focus where it
ought to be
where it will be every day
between now and the next general
election
on the future
on the sort of nation that britain can
be
and the sort of nation
labor wants it to be
because at the moment
britain is stuck
stuck with a tanking economy
stuck at home unable to get a passport
or a flight
stuck on the phone trying to book a gp
appointment
our taxes are going up
food and energy bills are out of control
and many of the public services that we
rely on
have simply stopped working
britain deserves better than this
we need a fresh start
[Applause]
i know i know you'd expect me to say
this but we're not going to get that
from a conservative party infected with
the chaos virus caught from boris
johnson
only labor can reboot our economy and
end the cost of living crisis
only labor can revitalize our public
services and re-energize our communities
only labor could unite the country and
clean up politics
these three tasks
will define my government
because until we address them
we leave ourselves vulnerable to the
shocks and crisis we've endured this
past long decade
yet the way i see it
the challenges we face
climate change
technology
and aging population are an opportunity
to re-energize britain
some nation
is going to lead the world in new
nuclear power
why not this one
some nation will create the first
generation of quantum computers why not
us
some nation will design medicines
personally to match our unique dna
why not britain
[Applause]
this
this determination to move britain
forward is what drives me
britain should be a competent and
prosperous nation
but at the moment it's full of people
worried about the next bill coming
through the letterbox
take zoey from sunderland
just down the road
like many people
zoe's gas and electricity bills have
doubled
she says
i'm struggling to get by
i haven't managed to full shop for food
in over a month
the cost of living is scaring me
and the future looks terrifying now i've
been up and down the country a lot
recently it's one of the good things
about this job
and let me tell you
i've heard a version of zoe's words from
almost everyone i've met
her words reflect the reality facing
millions of working people in britain
right now
people like my family
i didn't come from a privileged
background
my life my start in life was completely
ordinary
that was a tool maker
mum was a nurse
our house was a pebble dash semi and we
had a ford cortina
now this this was the 1970s
but i owe everything
all my values
to my upbringing
my work ethic and dedication to public
service
but the real gift my parents gave me
was the opportunity to get on
and that's why i came into politics
i've been lucky enough to take a journey
through my life
from a working class family to head of
the crown prosecution service
so when i say i don't want anyone in
this country held back by their
circumstances
you know it's not just words
it's why
for me
the state of our economy
is personal
because
when people like zoe are so scared about
the future
when our economy is so wracked by low
growth and insecurity
then working people get stuck
and that means britain gets stuck
the most important goal of my labor
government
will be to grow the economy
and we will not accept growth that
doesn't improve people's lives
an economy can grow
and leave some of its people behind
but a nation cannot grow in that way
not long ago i was in burnley
and i was left in no doubt by the people
i met there
they had great ambitions for themselves
and for their town
but they don't have a government that
shares that ambition
boosterism and wishful thinking are not
the same as ambition
and
and if you don't have a plan to make
your hopes real
all you're selling
is an illusion
[Applause]
now
the other thing my background gives me
is impatience
if you're born without privilege you
don't have time for messing around
you don't walk round problems without
fixing them
or surrender to the instincts of
organizations that look to preserve
themselves
rather than modernize
so believe it or not
i'm not that interested
in the political game
the daily saga who's up and who's down
in westminster no
not even this week or last
i'm impatient
to get things done
i can see what's wrong with britain and
i want to fix it
it's what i've done
with our own party
when i took this job on in april 2020
i knew we had a big task before us
we had to change our party and prepare
for power all in one go
not change for change sake
but change with a
purpose to remake a labour party
that understands its purpose is service
not self-indulgence
country first
party second
that
that's why we had to root out the
anti-semitism which had infected our
party
that's why we had to show our support
for nato is non-negotiable
show that we want business to thrive and
to prosper
and shed policies that won't work
the labour party was stuck
stuck in opposition
stuck licking its wounds after four
painful defeats
of course we still have more to do
but now labor is moving forward again
and this is what i will do for britain
and i will do it with a plan to tackle
the three biggest issues that we face
rebooting our economy and ending the
cost of living crisis
revitalizing our public services and
re-energizing our communities and
uniting the country and cleaning up
politics
[Applause]